ma c'est que vous êtes dans une émission
fait l'interview nul guide
ah oui oui je crains qu'elle ne
souhaiterait nul d est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère mon
père j'ai pas eu le temps de m'en lasser
parce que j'ai eu un père très distrait
donc de temps j'entends il y avait un
mec qui me kim a triplé qui met anglais
complètement tout ça je me dis j'ai eu
peur c'était beau père et puis j'avais
plus de nouvelles pendant cinq ans dans
ce bon père bon mon père c'était ça
quant à ma mère
ma mère c'est devenu un personnage de
fiction
j'en ai fait un personnage sur scène on
ne se voit plus beaucoup
je pense que l était pas dans la rue le
premier maire dans les manifestants non
non non non elisa minutes
oui oui oui il ya prescription à l'étagé
préfériez staline ou hitler il faudrait
compter les morts à savoir quel d2 tu es
le plus
tallinn je refuse de me prononcer je
préfère corbacho whisky et qui a été
épatant et c'est une des plus grandes
injustices de l'histoire que quand bois
de chauffe n'ai pas réussi à faire ce
qu'il voulait la pérestroïka et qu'on
ait mis ce soûlard de delsinne et
maintenant cette extraordinaire serial
killer qui continue il me fait peur
quand j'ai vu le camp du bien avec eux
bush
le champion de la peine de mort poutine
le tueur de tchétchènes ayant ses mines
l'homme de la place tiananmen le camp du
bien
mais ce spatiale vous partez trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial
on remettra une quenouille non non non
on est un petit peu à la politique
française
vous pouvez répartir avec sarkozy juppé
ou alliot marie je comprends c'est pas
facile comme j'ai du coeur je pars à
mais gagne maryse la belle eau
alors si vous aviez le choix ou
préfériez faire l'amour avec une fille
moche très moche ou un mec très beau
match et depuis que je veux tu iras que
je vais chez toi et aidera peut-être
toutefois sans me faire [ __ ]
c'est une question qui vous concerne
à qui accordez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ya des
vieilles gens ordinaires vente à
accepteriez-vous guy bedos d'échanger
une paralysie générale téva l'origine
contre la faim de la famine en afrique
non vraiment si jamais si jamais ça la
paralysie
je demanderai comme la fildak ont avoué
langage je demanderai l'euthanasie le
droit de mourir dans la dignité pour moi
c'est quelque chose de fantastique donc
alors d'accord sweet jane en afrique la
tétraplégie et l'euthanasie derrière
voilà bien je veux bien parce que je
suis un peu fatigué se voit pas trop ah
si vous aviez un perroquet voulu
apprendriez d'affirmer le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
je sais qu'on sait très content services
publics en même temps qu est la coco
système et qui c'est qui a préparé six
mois constitue prise elle avait pris la
quelle est à votre avis le sport le plus
con moi je veux pas perdre des clients 1
maintenant j'en ai un bon bout le
curling qui 6 1 c'est là où il ya un mec
qui balaient devant la truck avance tu
sais ah oui oui mais s'ils considéraient
il sera bien entendu tellement de mecs
qui font de curling qui vont voir vos
spectacles de toute façon moi non non
oui je prends pas de grands risques est
d'accord je cherche à tuer le football
se font mourier être réincarné en
marguerite duras ou en marilyn monroe
je crois là au point où on en est en
marine ou parce que j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour arthur muller j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer j'ai même adapté
une de ses pièces et avoir une histoire
d'amour totalement virtuel avec arthur
muller et des normes ni bar 20 sa charge
et une légère inflexion l'arrivée du
français préféré un président de la
république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout un président de la république
d'extrême droite
la question est mal formulée ça ne va
pas ensemble
il n'y a pas de république d'extrême
droite et à l'extrême droite où il ya la
république